[Music]
we're sitting inside
a 2019 infinity q50
we're gonna try and make a key for it
we're gonna use the
ninja t1000 top done we got from uhs
hardware
thank you very much and let's get
started
emergency allies first of all on
emo okay okay
we're gonna go to north america
sorry asia
infinity
as you can see the key
doesn't do anything
usa canada
q50 1419 proximity
program proximity key ignition is off
hazard are on
do not depress the brake pedal ensure
the maximum case of four keys okay all
keys will be deleted okay
keys are deleted as you can hear
we're gonna turn the ignition on
ignition is on
press okay
we're gonna shut off the ignition i'm
gonna press okay
now we're gonna press one time on the
push to start button
the light will blink we're gonna hold
the remote against the push to start
security let's flash five times we're
going to turn it off
we're going to turn it back on by
pressing with the remote
back off and as you can see steering
registration completed
now let's test working
i'm going to unplug the obd turn off the
[Music]
hazard
car is on
[Music]
car is locked
no no no remote stop on this car
[Music]